what's up gq i'm alyssia cara and these
are my essentials
[Music]
so where do i start i don't even know
which one to pick
this is a diffuser it's a weird
contraption
you put it at the end of your blow dryer
it's for curly hair
so if you've ever seen my hair
completely frizzy it's either like i
didn't have one of these
or like i couldn't find it or i didn't
have time to diffuse my hair and i just
had to blow dry it like some hotels
especially in europe like i can't use my
hair dryer because of the plug like
it'll explode i've had
a hair dryer blow up but i've figured
out ways to manage without it like air
drying it is fine but
this just makes it so much better and it
adds so much volume to my hair
and just makes it look a lot nicer the
next thing
is this perfume by lancome called la vie
belle i've been wearing this for
a few years now i was at an airport i
tried this one and i loved it so much
but i didn't have any money on me so i
was like ah i'll get it later
and then my tech leo who's amazing he
had his like card on him so he like went
back to the store and bought it for me
which is so nice and he came back with
it i was like oh thank you so much
and ever since i just keep buying them
and it's like my favorite i have like
five of these
just at home i feel like it's like my
signature scent everybody knows
me by this scent it's so strong my best
friend like always likes to joke around
with me because like
i'll leave a room and like she'll know i
was there one time when we were on tour
she like had to like come into my
hotel room for something and she didn't
know the room number and she's like i
literally just followed your scent
and she found my room so this is like my
holy grail i love it i'm gonna spray it
now i haven't worn it today oh my god
it's the best thing in the world it
smells like candy
and flowers and something about the ph
balance but my skin just works
oh my god such a mess there's like
things piled on top of each other
the next thing is my usb
microphone this also looks like a weird
contraption
but this is great for traveling i always
travel with this
i have actually recorded a lot of my
stuff in quarantine with this
i recorded my song a little more on this
it's awesome it's just like
the best thing because you can just plug
it right into your laptop you don't even
need an interface
i really love recording with this and i
find that if you just
have the right eq on it and just like
edit the vocals great it just sounds
like a professional mic you don't even
need a pop filter
you just kind of use it all the way back
here and that's how i record a lot of
demos some of those demos make it to my
actual recordings
it's raining it's raining so hard
it's like thunderstorming outside um but
i actually don't know
where i got this i really don't remember
but i've had it for years and it's like
my favorite thing
ever sometimes my brother will steal it
he'll like come into my room in the
middle of the night and be like can i
use your mic
i'm like for what he just takes it so
maybe he's doing some secret studio
sessions in his room i don't know
fenty gloss this is
my favorite gloss ever ever since i
discovered it like three years ago
it's all i wear this is the gloss balm
one so there's like the clear one which
is really good but this one is my
favorite it's like
the perfect shade of like pink and like
shimmer in it and it's not sticky it
just makes
your lips look so nice and i feel like
everybody of any skin
tone just wears this and looks amazing
so shout out rhianna
she has a lot of my money that's for
sure i met rihanna
once it was like a really quick um
interaction but i
was in like this little house that she
rented to write for her
and i had to pass the kitchen and then i
just heard her voice and i was like
that's her she was just so beautiful and
so sweet and kind and
like i went in for the handshake and she
went in for the hug so it was a little
awkward but
we made it through this is an
old-fashioned espresso maker this is
what my family uses
i have a regular espresso machine too
but this is just the old-fashioned way
it makes your coffee just so much better
i am italian so that means a lot of
coffee a lot of espresso
i grew up drinking coffee my whole life
since i was like five
my go-to breakfast was like cookies and
coffee with milk i was having lattes at
like
freaking five years old this one's a
really small one so this is like what i
usually use for myself
at my own house you open it
and you put water in here
and then you put this like little filter
on the top and then you put the coffee
at the top and you tighten it and you
just put it over the stove
and then you just wait and your coffee
will start brewing and you lift
and you'll start to see like seeing
coffee come out of it it's the best it's
the best
the best way to make coffee in the world
in the summertime i'll like make it cold
like a cold brew espresso and i'll have
it just
plain i'm starting to get into the plain
black coffee but typically i like just
like an oat milk
or some sort of like alternative milk
i'm like very addicted to it i wonder
why i have anxiety and then i realize i
have
so much espresso since i was five so
that's probably
the culprit okay this one's a little bit
boring
but it really is like an essential for
my life
i need headphones yes these are the
wired ones
i do not like air pods i like to have
the feeling of a
wire i like to know where both my
headphones are at the same time
i don't want to have to charge them so
this is perfect i can't get into a car
in the passenger seat or in the back
without having headphones in it's just
like my favorite thing to do
in the world just put my headphones in
listen to music and just like watch the
road
for hours and hours it's actually become
like so much of a habit that i get a
little anxious like if i get into a car
without them
so if i lose them like people who know
me know like if i lose my headphones i'm
like where are they like i lost my
headphones you guys like how am i gonna
do this
on a plane i need them i'm sort of
obsessive with my headphones but i
i need them in my life at all times i
always like every time i
make like a demo i always listen to it
on these because that's how a majority
of fans listen to music too so it's nice
to get that perspective
but whoever i've been listening to janae
eco's deluxe version of her album is so
good
leanne the havos just released a new
album which is amazing i've loved her
for years so
that's what i've been digging into these
last few months
next thing is a film or disposable
or like polaroid camera this is a film
one that i got from like this
weird mall i went to go develop some
film pictures and
the guy was really really nice and he
gave me and my friend a free
little film camera it was the sweetest
thing ever because my other one broke so
he was like
just take this i'm like that's so nice
so i cherish this one
it doesn't have any film in it now but i
always carry like a disposable camera
with me or like a polaroid one it's
i think the best way to take pictures i
feel like when you're taking photos on a
phone
everyone's always like let me see or
like let's take another one but this is
like
totally candid you can't see what they
look like so it's just one and done
and you always capture like the coolest
little moments i think
honestly i feel like there's no thrill
better
than like waiting for a film to be
developed and then like
seeing it for the first time and seeing
what photos you took it's the best thing
because you often like forget
especially if you're on tour and then
you develop them months later
you forget what pictures you took and
then you remember and it's the best
feeling
it's never really me which is i think i
want to try to do more is like getting
my friends to take pics of me because if
you were to see like my photo albums
like i'm not in them so it's like i
wasn't there
in any of those moments because i'm
always like taking them my best friend
live she's good with that she'll always
take pictures of me which is nice
because at least
there's proof that i was there next
this is mario badescu skin
care facial spray with aloe herbs and
rose water established in 1967
it's like this really hydrating spray
that you can use as a setting spray
just to hydrate your face throughout the
day i have like a thousand bottles of
these as you can tell this one is like
almost done
but i just love to just spray it on my
face it
smells like roses and sometimes like an
old lady like your grandma
like think of your grandmother it's
probably what this smells like
but it's very good i feel like it just
hydrates my face and
just makes me feel like i'm taking care
of it throughout the day don't know
exactly what it's supposed to be used
for i just think it's hydrating and nice
and it sets your makeup
actually pretty well i don't have a
specific way that i spray it i think i
just put too much
like that's my way it's just like
i just love the look of just being like
like i just came out like inside from
the rain
like like i was just rained on all over
my face and i feel like you can never
have too much of it you can never be too
dewy that's that's my thing you can
never look too sweaty
every time i'm on like red carpets and
stuff or like on tv like the makeup
people will come and like put powder on
my face they're like oh you're a little
shiny i'm like oh
i love the shine i just love looking
like a pearl
the next essential is this backpack
or any mini backpack for that matter i
like to rotate backpacks every few
months i don't like purses
because i feel like they're just
annoying to carry like on one side this
is great because it's plain
it's black it goes with everything
there's enough that can fit in here
my phone my headphones of course my mask
i have bigger backpacks too but i find
like for just a regular day
many backpacks are the best i don't like
to put too much stress on my back
so these are perfect because they fit
everything i need and it's not like
giant i'm not like going hiking you know
this one is
oh this is roots a canadian brand i have
every every kind though there's like
designs on them i have like a chrome
looking one
i have a striped one a floral one i have
like every
every kind of backpack but this is the
one i like right now
because it's just really plain cute
this is my midi keyboard
i always travel with this this is the
best thing if you
like to produce and if you're like
working remotely or
traveling a lot this is the best thing
to have because it fits in your backpack
and you can basically produce anything
on these if you have like a program i
use logic
i'm trying to get into pro tools but
logic is the one that i know
best it's perfect because you can just
plug it into your computer it's another
usb
thing so i can plug this in and my mic
and just like make
beats you can play keys you can turn
this into a drum pad
i've had this one for about four years
now
i think i've been using it for a while i
started using it a lot
when i did the coldplay tour i got to
open for them which is
crazy but i had like so much time since
i was an opener
to like you know be in my dressing room
and i didn't really know what to do so
my drummer adrien was like why don't you
get like a midi keyboard i was like
what's a mini keyboard
and he told me what it was he borrowed
he let me borrow his for a while and
then i got my own and i just like
used it all the time and i still do it's
how i make a lot of my
demos and stuff so here's an example i'm
here with gq
and i'm here to say hope you have a
super fun day
[Applause]
[Music]
all right gq those are my essentials
thank you so much for watching
bye